Georgia state lawmaker refuses to resign
over an appearance on a satirical TV
show he admits was ridiculously ugly
Jason Spencer is seen yelling the n-word
and exposing his rear end in the latest
episode of Sacha Baron Cohen's new show
who is America our craftsman is at the
Georgia State House in Atlanta with the
backlash mark good morning good morning
state representative Jason Spencer was
already a controversial figure here
he had previously tried to get wearing
burkas banned in public and had
threatened a black lawyer who opposed
Confederate statues now despite this
latest bigoted performance he vows to
stay in office and insists he was
tricked I am going to teach you how to
use your buttocks to intimidate Isis
Georgia state lawmaker Jason Spencer
says he thought an ex Israeli military
officer was teaching him self-defense
instead he was captured on camera
showing his buttocks and shouting racial
slurs these seconds to attack the
tension go you crazy
the n-word is loony not this world this
world is disgusting his instructor also
trains him how to spot a terrorist
hiding under a burqa by surreptitiously
taking nude photos but that instructor
is actually Sacha Baron Cohen in
disguise the British comedian known for
his other alter egos
[Music]
Bora Ivana best star Bruno booyakasha
and Ali G who wants to see huge economic
growth here this is the second episode
of Cohen's controversial series who is
American soul in which he uses a stable
of new characters anyone from average
Americans is it possible to assign my
water-borne sure like former Vice
President Dick Cheney which was your
favorite warm and why oh I think it was
what we did in Desert Storm the program
airs on Showtime division of CBS state
representative Spencer said in a
statement Sacha Baron Cohen and his
associates took advantage of my
paralyzing fear that my family would be
attacked I deeply regret the language I
used at his request all you damned sick
never in the eight Middle East Spencer
may have felt embarrassed but Georgia's
Republican leaders were thought governor
nathan Deal said he was saddened and
disgusted House Speaker David Ralston
and both Republicans running to become
the next governor demanded Spencer
stepped down that is not being
politically incorrect that's just be an
unacceptable behavior that he should
certainly not only apologize but you
know go ahead and resign his seat
Spencer lost his re-election bid two
months ago if he refuses to resign he'll
serve the remaining five months of his
term john mark thank you